Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing into
the chapter regarding patience,
the merits, the rulings, the
rewards of patience, etc.
Authored by imi.
And before we begin the next verse
explaining the next verse, he begins
this chapter with about seven verses
from the Quran. Select verses discussing
the topic.
Before we begin with that, I'd to
bring to everyone's attention
a detail that perhaps some of us know,
perhaps is the first time for others,
that in the battle of Azb,
also known as the battle of the trench,
the battle of the confederates.
This battle was one of the most scary
and frightening battles that the
companions had ever endured.
And the reason for that
is multiffold.
Number one,
they had to rely heavily
on
other people in Medina who were known
as backstabbers.
They had to rely on
some of the in Medina who were known to
constantly
prove treacherous in any treaty they
sign.
Number two, they were going to have more
enemies than they had ever had before
at one time.
Number three, they were in Medina this
time and so the stakes were much higher.
Why is that? If the enemy was able to to
penetrate
the walls of the city and get inside of
the city and by somehow
it it proves a loss for the believers,
it will be devastating to not only the
military but the women, the children,
the elders, combatants,
non-combatants, and all of their wealth.
the city would be completely pillaged.
Number four was the season in which this
battle took place. It was bitter cold,
but
in addition to the cold, they could not
rely on the desert climate to act as an
aid.
A final point that made this battle so
difficult
is that all of the Arabs had banded
together against the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and his companions.
They all banded together.
They were all one hand united.
United against what? This was in itself
a miracle. The Arabs had never been
united in such a way before this day.
It took their hatred of Allah and his
messenger,
their hatred ofahillah,
and their unanimous
despise for the implications of this new
religion, what they claim is new,
in order for them to band together
against a common enemy.
So, in itself, it was a miracle. It was
very miraculous that these tribes that
were initially waring with each other
sometimes for centuries on end
over the most petty of things.
You find that they are banded together
hand in hand
hand in hand side by side against
this common enemy. So they were very
very
dispersed.
They were all differing with each other
but they all agreed on their unanimous
hatred of the prophet sallallahu alaii
wasam the Quran and the believers.
Now this was an extremely terrifying
event for them
to the point that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala described
amongst the strongest of the companions
as
that the hearts were in the throats not
just by any men not by soft handed
dames. These were the companions.
These were the most valiant,
valorous
warriors history has ever seen.
And this is their state of fear.
However,
one thing really, really stands out.
What is that?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala described
their level of fear.
But he also
described
their morale.
He also described their mantra. He also
described their internal
interminable
dialogue.
What was going through the minds and
hearts of the believers? What were they
saying at this critical moment? Not with
their tongues, not what were they
uttering. What were they saying in their
heart of hearts?
They were saying
incredible.
They were saying this is exactly the
believers. This is exactly what Allah
and his messenger promised.
And this is exactly what Allah and his
messenger promised.
This is the fulfillment of that promise.
And Allah and his messenger have are
ever true.
Are ever true. Now notice this wording.
This is incredible.
What What is
in reference to what are they saying?
This is what Allah and his messenger
promised us.
They didn't say
this is what Allah and his messenger
threatened us with. No, they said this
is what Allah and his messenger promised
us.
What what are they referring to?
They are referring to the
difficulty, the trial, the tribulation,
the fear. This is what Allah and his
messenger promised would happen just
before the sun rises.
And so even though they were scared,
they were cold, they were uncertain,
they were reliant on people that are
lower than cockroaches.
However, on top of that, it was a kind
of comfort for them. It was a major
comfort that kept them steadfast that
this is what Allah and his messenger
have promised.
What are they referring to? the promise
of difficulty.
The scholars say, "If you want to know
who is upon the truth, look at what the
arrows unite against as a target.
If you want to get a good feel for who
is upon the truth,
look at whom the you the the arrows of
antagonists unite against as a target,
right?
Because
as the Arab idiom goes
that
What does this mean? If you imagine with
me, very very tall trees. Many of us who
grew up overseas, we had fruit trees
that were very tall. And people when
they would have their eye on a
particular fruit that looked
particularly succulent,
you'd take a stone and try to knock it
out of the tree. Right? Many of us grew
up doing this.
And so which tree gets the most stones
thrown at it? Only the tree with the
most fruits and the best fruits.
Trees that are
sterile. Trees that don't have any
fruits on them, nobody's throwing stones
at them. They're leaving them alone.
And so this next verse that we're going
to read,
this verse is the promise that the
companions were referring to when they
said, "This is what Allah and his
messenger promised us." In surah bakar
verse number 155 Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said
this is before he said
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala that which
translates to And verily
indeed we are going to test you all with
a portion of fear and hunger and a lack
of wealth
and bodies and fruits
and give glad tidings
to the patient.
So the the verse you would expect that a
verse that is so daunting at the
beginning
and indeed we are going to send
tribulation and hardship your way. You
wouldn't expect the end of the verse to
be and give the good news.
You wouldn't expect that to be the end
of the verse.
But the but this is the miracle of the
Quran and this is the beauty of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala's
his how he raises and cultivates the
hearts and souls. He gives us what we
need not necessarily what we want and
what we want is rarely ever what we need
as human beings. So the verse starts
with we are going to inflict pain upon
you. Good news. Good news for you. And
this is why the scholars referred to
this verse as a guest, an honored guest
sent by Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
amongst the companions.
We will talk about the details of this
[Arabic recitation]
But as a parting thought,
if you were to imagine with me a
jeweler,
a goldsmith
who has raw gold that needs to be
purified
before he can make it into something
that is
some kind of jewelry, something that
people will want, something that people
will will will admire.
He has to purify it. He has to get it
ready. He has to after purifying it, he
has to then cut it and stamp it and bend
it. And it's a very strange process.
It's a very violent process. Now, if you
imagine with me, if he has
different pieces of gold there of
different
value and different purity, which
pieces of gold are going to get the most
attention from the jeweler?
Is it going to be the lowest quality
gold with the lowest potential?
Or is the jeweler going to give his most
most of his attention and priority to
the gold that he knows he can make the
best out of and that gold will make the
best for him.
And so
the tribulations and trials and
difficulties, they're not fun. However,
they are a sign that the jeweler is
[Arabic recitation]